السعوديه نحو الفضاء ساعات تفصلنا عن
انطلاق الرحله التاريخيه هو محمد رمضان
وجدل جديد سببه الاستعراض والماسك يكشف عن
غلطه وندما عليها ويعترف كنت احمق كبير
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ينطلق بعد ساعات حدث تاريخي سعودي عنوانه
متصدر الاخبار والمنصات وكمان ترند وهو
السعوديه النحو الفضاء فرائده الفضاء
السعوديين علي القرني وريان البرناوي
سينطلق في مهمه
فضاء امريكيين كمان على نفس الرحله هذه
المهمه هي احدى مبادرات الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء واللي انطلقت لتعزيز مكانه
السعوديه في مجال الفضاء وتطوير قدراتها
ضمن رؤيه 2030 الليله راح ينطلق صاروخ
فالكون 9 اللي بيحمل مركبه دراغون 2 في
رحله التنقيب واستكشاف الفضاء واللي راح
تستمر 12 يوم وسيشارك فيها الفريق السعودي
ب 14 تجربه فضائيه سته منها في الدماغ
والجهاز العصبي واربعه منا في الخلايا
المناعيه وتجربه في الاستمطار وثلاثه
تجارب تعليميه توعويه
عشره تسعه ثمانيه سبعه سته خمسه اربعه
ثلاثه اثنين
واحد مستعدين الانطلاق
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
في السعوديه نحو الفضاء
[موسيقى]
هذه بخصوص الرحله اما عن رائده الفضاء
فريانا برناويه او الرائده فضاء السعوديه
عربيه مسلمه عمرها 33 سنه ومعاها
بكالوريوس في علم الهندسه الوراثيه وتطوير
وماجستير في العلوم الطبيه وبتعمل حاليا
كمان في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي
كاخصائيه في الابحاث المخبريه وكانت نشرت
من ساعات تغريده عن موعد انطلاق الرحله
وطلبت من الناس متابعه التحديثات على حساب
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء وارفقتها بصوره
لها
احساسه بالفخر بهذه المهمه اكبر شعور
العشر
من اهم محاور رؤيه 2030 دعم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه للمراه من اهداف
الباحثين والعلماء والمطورين اللي على
الارض يجربوا تجاربهم هادي في الفضاء دوري
الان هو اني امثل المملكه في هذه المهمه
العلميه علامات الرحله اي اكس 2 وتعد هذه
البعثات الفضائيه هي احدى ثمار هذه الرؤيه
ويوصل طموحنا لعنان السماء
[موسيقى]
مع القرن فهو اول رائد فضاء سعودي يصل
للمحطه الدوليه ومن مواليد سنه 92 وعنده
بكالوريوس في علوم الطيران من كليه الملك
فيصل الجويه في الرياض وبيعمل مقاتل على
طائرات اف 15 برتبه نقيب طيار في القوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه علي كمان شارك مع
متابعي على تويتر الكثير من التغريدات
المتعلقه بالرحله بس يمكن من اكثر ما
تفاعل مع الناس صوره شنطته اللي ماخذها مع
الفضاء في وسط كل الحماس والاستعدادات
للرحله ما احد جاء على باله رواد الفضاء
ايش بياخدوا في شنطهم وكان كمان شارك مع
الناس مجموعه من التدريبات اللي عملها قبل
ما تنطلق المهمه وكيف استعد لها
اختياري من ضمن برنامج رواد الفضاء
السعوديين يعتبر اكبر انجاز لي في حياتي
سامثل الوطني المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
هذه الرحله العلميه وهي مسؤوليه كبيره جدا
ونحمل رايه كبيره
وطبعا التفاعل مع علي وريانه كبير جدا
واسمهم وحساباتهم في كل مكان على المنصات
وجالسين بنشوفها في كل تغريده وبوس
حساباتهم مع انها جديده نسبيا والمتابعين
عليها بعشرات الالوف لسه لكنهم بيزيدوا
بشكل كبير لحظه بلحظه والمشاهدات والتفاعل
مع الحسابات واضحه جدا صوره علي اللي
تكلمنا عنها مثلا عليها اكثر من مليون
مشاهده وصوره ريان اللي نزلتها من كم يوم
لاخر يوم لها قبل العزل اللي بيسبق السفر
للفضاء عليها اكثر من مليون و600 الف
مشاهده وعلى فكره حتى الاطفال كان لهم
نصيب من التفاعل ففي طفل اسمه هاشم العلوي
بيقول عن نفسه رائد فضاء المستقبل طلع في
فيديو ووجه نصائح لعلي وريان قبل رحلتهم
[موسيقى]
على نصائحه ووعدوا انهم راح يلتزموا فيها
احنا معانا من مركز كندي للفضاء موقع
انطلاق المهمه مراسل العربيه حسين الطوط
اهلا فيك معنا حسين يوم يعني جميل وتاريخي
اذا تحكي لنا الاجواء عندك كيف يبدو وعندك
حر كمان الشمس يبدو قويه
جدا هو يوم تاريخي خطوه عملاقه والاجواء
حماسيه في انتظار في ظل انتظار الرواد لكي
ياتوا بعد ساعه ونصف تقريبا عبر مروحيه
الى هنا الى مركز كندي حيث سيلوحون
لاهاليهم ولاصدقائهم قبل ان يستلمهم فريق
سبيس اكس على الساعه الواحده والربع
لاجراء التحضيرات النهائيه قبل الدخول الى
المركبه الفضائيه ثم الانطلاق باذن الله
تعالى الى الفضاء الخارجي طبعا هذا
الاجواء كما قلنا صحيح هناك حرب لكن هناك
ايضا
نوع من الجو اللطيف اليوم كما اخبرنا
العاملون هنا في وكاله ناسا الصاروخ عندما
سينطلق ساره اذا سمحت لي
هو يتكون جسده من مركبه فضائيه دراغون وهي
اول مركبه فضائيه خاصه لنقل البشر الى
المحطه الدوليه الفضائيه عندما ينطلق
الجزء الثاني من الصاروخ وهو صاروخ فالكون
يتكون من قسمين القسم الاكبر يتضمن تسع
محركات عندما يصل الى ارتفاع 80 كيلو مترا
فوق سطح البحر
ويصل الى سرعه صوت مضاعفه الى عشر مرات
سينفصل هذا القسم ليسقط في البحر ثم يبدا
القسم الثاني ذات المحرك الواحد بالعمل
لمده سبع دقائق تقريبا حتى يضع المركبه في
مدار فضائل معين وينفصل هو ايضا بنفسه ثم
تتحرك المركبه تدور حول الارض لتخفف
سرعتها حتى تلتحم بالمحطه الفضائيه وقد
يستغرق ذلك سته عشر ساعه
عندما يصل الرواد علي وريان الفضاء
الامريكيين الى المحطه سيبداون باجراء
اختبارات عديده 14 اختبارا
يختبرون تاثير الجاذبيه على الاعضاء
البشريه اختبارات علميه اخرى هو برنامج
طموح في الحقيقه يسعى به
حسين اذا تحكيلنا انت ذكرت انه في تحضيرات
سبقت الرحله وانه لسه في تحضيرات لمن
حيوصلوا الان اذا تحكيلنا عن هذه
التحضيرات اللي سبقت والتحضيرات اللي
بتنتظرهم الان
التحذيرات التي سبقت هي تدريبات هي اجراء
محاكاه للاختبارات التي التي سيقومون بها
اختبارات للصحه الجسديه لرواد الفضاء ايضا
تدريب على كيفيه قياده المركبه عندما تصعد
الى الفضاء كيفيه اجراء المختبرات هناك
محاكاه يقومون بها على سطح الارض عندما
يصلون الى هنا
سيقومون باختبارات اخيره الاستعداد كما
قيل على موقع
الوكاله الهيئه الفضائيه السعوديه هي
انتهت البارحه لسدادات النهائيه ولكن هناك
استعدادات ما قبل الانطلاق سيقومون بها
عندما يستلم فريق سبايكس اكس الرواد
الاربعه هي هي استعدادات الروتينيه اخيره
اللمسات الاخيره هذا صح التعبير قبل
دخولهم الى
المركبه في الصاروخ ثم باذن الله ينطلقون
الى الفضاء هذا اجراء روتيني طبعا عندما
تحدثنا الى مسؤولين فيها ناس هنا سالناهم
هل يمكن يكون هناك تاخير الناس اعطت
ويندوز فتره زمنيه الصاروخ يجب ان ينطلق
على الساعه الخامسه والنصف في توقيت
فلوريدا ولكن اذا تاخر قليلا قد ينطلق على
الساعه التاسعه والنصف بتوقيت فلوريدا
ولكنهم يتوقعون بان يكون اليوم جميل بان
لا يكون هناك اي اضطرار لتاخير هذه الرحله
يتوقون ان لا تكون هناك مشاكل وتنطلق بخير
وسلامه الى الفضاء واهلهم موجودين حسين
صحيح حسين حيكونوا شايفين اهل ريانه وعلي
صحيح الاهل سياتون بعد قليل سيكونون هنا
في بالقرب من هذا المكان سينتظرون اولادهم
حتى ياتون عندما ياتي الرواد سيلوحون لهم
لكن هناك مسافه اخبرنا الموظفون في
المسافه بسبب
ابتعاد عنه بسبب الامراض هم كانوا بحجر
يحافظوا على هذه المسافه لن يقتربوا من
العاملين كثيرا سيروحون من بعيد لكنهم
سيرونهم سيتحدثون معهم عن بعيد ثم سيدخلون
الى المركز حيث يستقبلهم كما قلنا فريق من
سبيس طبعا انت باقي في متابعه هذا الموضوع
وحتكون معانا كمان في النشرات القادمه وفي
تغطيه طبعا كبيره على العربيه لهذا اليوم
التاريخي انا بشكرك على هذه المعلومات كان
معنا من مركز كندي للفضاء موقع انطلاق
المهمه مراسل العربيه حسين التوت شكرا لك
حسين
محمد رمضان نشر صور على حساباته وهو راجع
من امريكا بطياره خاصه وجنبه على الكرسي
رزم من الدولارات الصوره اشعلت جدل كبير
جدا وانتقادات مو اول مره يواجهها محمد
رمضان حقيقه وهي انتقادات التباهي بالفلوس
وما حد عارف لو الانتقادات هي السبب او
ايش لكن محمد رمضان رجع وحذف الصور وخلى
بس صوره واحده واضحه فيها الدولارات من
زاويه ضيقه جدا الناس انتقدت الاستعراض
وخصوصا انه في كثير ناس ظروفه صعبه ومصر
فيها ازمه دولار هذا غير تبعات التعويم
ومن بين الناس كمان اللي هاجموا رمضان
كانت دكتور جمال شعبان طبيب بامراض القلب
اللي رد على صور محمد رمضان قال له في انه
يا ريت بالدولارات اللي معاك تشتري منظمات
كهربائي منظمات كهربائيه للغلابه اللي في
العنايه المركزه وعندهم احتمال السكته
والتوقف القلبي المفاجئ مجرد على بوست
الدكتور من محمد رمضان اللي طلب منه اسماء
المستشفيات اللي بحاجه للاجهزه وطلب كمان
رقم تليفون دكتور وقال الدكتور انه تكلم
مع رمضان واتفقوا انه يزور احدى القرى
الفقيره معه ويساعد الناس اللي محتاجين
فيها وانه راح يتم تحديد حالات طارئه عشان
يساعدوهم وقال كمان انه اقترح على محمد
رمضان تاسيس جمعيه خيريه وانه رحب بالفكره
كمان والموضوع ما توقف هنا لا جدل الصور
وصل لمكان رسمي تحديدا احنا بنتكلم عن قبه
البرلمان صار في تحرك برلماني ضد رمضان
فاحدى النائبات وجهت مذكره لرئيس المجلس
طالبت فيها وزير الماليه ورئيس مصلحه
الضرائب في مصر بتوضيح اذا كان محمد رمضان
بيدفع الضرائب اللي مترتبه عليه وقالت ان
محمد رمضان اللي بيسمي نفسه نمبر وان هو
اعلى الفنانين اجرا في مصر وانه ولا مره
طول مشواره الفني قدم اسهامات او مشاركات
مجتمعيه مثل غيرهم من الفنانين وقالت كمان
انه واجه في يونيو 2020 اتهام بالتهرب
الضريبي لانه قدم اقرارات ضريبي او قدم
اقرار تحديد ضري في بيانات صحيحه عن ارباح
ومكاسبه واخفى ارقام دخلوا الرسميه
والصحيحه طيب للتذكير مشاهدينا هذه المره
الاولى لمحمد رمضان بيثير الجدل بصوره
اللي بيعتبرها كثير من الناس استعراض
للفلوسه فمن قبل طلع في فيديو هو بيرمي
الدولارات في مسبح وكانت قصه كبيره وهذا
غير الصور اللي بين فتره وفتره بينزلها
والناس بتعتبرها استعراض لاسطول سياراته
الفارهه في مره ثانيه كمان صارت ازمه وجدل
برضه بسبب فيديو عرض في فرشه اسنان ومعجون
اسنان من الذهب
بعد اشهر بن القتال بين قوات فاجنر والجيش
الاوكراني في مدينه بخموت اعلن قائد قوات
باجنر اللي بتقاتل لجانب روسيا اعلن امس
السيطره الكامله على المدينه وظهر عناصر
في مقطع بيرفعوا رايتهم على اعلى نقطه في
المدينه وبدا الكرملين يهنئ بعد نروي
الجانب الاوكراني ينفي الاخبار ويقول لهم
صحيح دخلوا المدينه لكنها مو تحت سيطرتهم
وبين الاخذ والرد وبين النفي والتهنئه
شفنا على تويتر الدعوه لزياره مخ فنائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري استغل
الفرصه ودعى الى الماسك لزياره المدينه من
بعد السيطره عليها طبعا ما ننسى انه ماسك
من الاول كان دخل على خط الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
فمره عمل استطلاع على تويتر اقترح فيه خطه
للسلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا لطلب منهم
التصويت عليه وهذا عمل له ازمه مع
الاوكران هذا غير خدمه كمان ستار لينك
للانترنت اللي هي تابعه له واللي زود فيها
الاوكرانيين وهذه عملت له مشكله
[موسيقى]
على العموم ماسك للامن مرض على الدعوه
نكمل حلقتنا مع خبر تاني متعلق بالون ماسك
في الملياردير اخباره اليوم مو بس متعلقه
بالسياسه والحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بل
كمان بموضوع ملح وكثر الحديث عنه مؤخرا
وصاير طبعا عنوان اساسي معانا طبعا نحن
بنتكلم هنا عن الذكاء الاصطناعي من اوائل
الناس اللي استثمروا في الذكاء الاصطناعي
ورجع لاحقا اعرب عن ندم وعلى الموضوع وصار
من قاده المعسكر اللي بيدعو لتخفيف
استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي وتقنين الموضوع
ويحذر من خطورته وفي مقابله مع سي ان بي
سي من كم يوم جددت موقفه
ماسك ما حضر عموما من الذكاء الاصطناعي
وبس لكن كمان اعرب عن الندم الشديد عند
فيما يتعلق تحديدا في استثمارات السابقه
في شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي نحن بنتكلم هنا
ترى عن تحديدا open مؤسسها
شفتوا
جوجل كانت مسيطره على سوق الذكاء
الاصطناعي تماما لكن اعترف كمان انه قلل
بينه وبين نفسه بدايه من open اي وانه كان
احمق كبير لما نستخف فيها مسكن من مؤسسي
الشركه وتركها في 2018 بسبب خلافات مع
المؤسسين التنين طيب بعدها بسناء الشركه
اللي بدات غير ربحيه تحولت لي ربحيه ماسك
وجه سهام في تصريحاته كمان لاحد مؤسسي
جوجل اللي قال انه حضره مرارا من مخاطر
الذكاء الاصطناعي على البشريه لكن مؤسس
جوجل ما كان فارق معاه
انا المسكو مؤسس جوجل كانوا اعز اصحاب
بحسب كلام ماسكو خسروا بعضهم بسبب خلافهم
في وجهات النظر بخصوص الذكاء الاصطناعي
تصريحات ايلون ماسك عن اوبن اي اي فتح
فيها جبهه صراع ثانيه بينه وبين
مايكروسوفت حذر من التحكم الاكبر
للمايكروسوفت في الاوبن اي اليوم وقال انه
الموضوع اكبر مما يظن قاده الشركه
مايكروسوفت ما استقبلت التصريحات بهدوء
ابدا وطلع رئيسها وقال انه شركته ما
بتسيطر على اوبن اي اي كما يدعي ماسك
للعلم مايكروسوفت بدات الاستثمار في اوبن
اي اي 2019 وللان حجم استثماراتها
التراكميه في الشركه 13 مليار دولار
جورجيا دوله اوروبيه كانت يوما ما جزء من
الاتحاد السوفيتي ومثل معظم الدول اللي
مثل هالبلد مقسومه ناس مع روسيا والناس ضد
وميالين لاوروبا والغرب والدوله يعني من
الدول الطامحه في الانضمام للاتحاد
الاوروبي ومقدم الطلب في هذا الخصوص لكن
الدنيا جورجيا حاليا مولعه تظاهرات والسبب
العلاقات مع روسيا القصه انه في 2019 قامت
مظاهرات في تبليسي ضد موسكو فقامت موسكو
وحضرت الطيران مع جورجيا من كم يوم بدون
سابق انذار انذار طلع بوتين واعلن استئناف
الطيران مع جورجيا مو بس كده لكن كمان قال
انه الجورجيين ما يحتاجوا فيزا لدخول
روسيا اكثر من الجورجيين مو عاجبهم
الموضوع وطلعوا مظاهرات واشتبكوا مع
الشرطه ولعت الدنيا بالشوارع ومعظم
المحتاجين خايفين يكون هذا مدخل لتوسيع
نفوذ روسيا في البلد او انه الموضوع ياثر
على طلب الانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي
الاشتباكات هذه انتقلت من الشارع ووصلت
كمان لقبه البرلمان اللي النواب في
مسكو في بعض شيء مع او شيء ضد استئناف
الطيران مع روسيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جورجيا مياله للغرب ومنتقده القرار
وحساباتها مشغله اعتراض على القرار لكن
الاكثار ما يعرفونه جورجيا منصب رئيس
الدوله منصب شرفي واللي بيحكم فعليا هو
الحكومه ورئيسها ورئيس الحكومه مع القرار
وميال لروسيا كل اللي قلت لكم هذا هو
خلفيه للخبر اللي جاي واللي حقيقه من اغرب
ما يكون فاللي صار انه رئيس جورجيا اعترضت
على القرار وقالت انه راح تقاطع الخطوط
الجورجيه لانها استانفت رحلاتها مع روسيا
لهنا نص العجب خلينا نشوف النص التالي
رئيس الدوله حتقاطع شرطه يعني او انه شركه
طيران بلدها يعني لكن الاعجب انه شركه
الطيران ردت وقالت انه هي اللي راح تحضر
الرئيسه من استقلال طائراتها وسمتها شخص
غير مرغوب فيه وقالت لها ترى ما حنشيل
الحظر الى ان تعتذري من الشعب
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم ان نعود
والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه جديده من
تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]